In all honesty, I'm going to start
by admitting that I sometimes lie.
Occasionally, I'll include a lie in a story
I'm telling if I think it'll make the story better.
I don't do it to protect the innocent,
because I don't know any stories where
the people in them are innocent.
And I don't do it to be shocking either,
though I admit to once telling a story where I exaggerated
the length of my penis.
In my own defense, I exaggerated down and not up.
And I did it for the laugh.
The story I'm telling you tonight does not have a lie in it,
or many laughs for that matter.
When I'm done telling you this story, you may think
it's nothing but a lie, but I'd ask you to trust me on this.
At the age of 19, I fell prey to a powerful and deeply
corrupting influence.
It dogged me for six years, costing me many a friend,
and in the process bringing my family to ruin.
It crippled me to such an extent that I
have spent the intervening 15 years recovering from it.
The influence I speak of is hope.
Now, you should know at the get go,
there's nothing in my childhood to suggest
I might find myself on such a wayward path as that.
My parents loved me terribly.
They taught me right from wrong.
They taught me to be courageous in the face of bullies.
They taught me patience and forgiveness.
They taught me that love would see you
through any misfortune.
My trouble began on Independence Day.
Not the Independence Day, but my Independence Day.
My Independence Day occurred on Memorial Day, 1982.
That was the day I told my family I was gay.
The act itself, mom, dad, I'm gay,
was relatively unexceptional.
In fact, it should have been more exceptional,
and I've always sort of wished that it had been.
However, subsequent events overshadowed it,
and it pales by comparison.
The subsequent events occurred in my absence,
after the fact, as I was in my car driving back to college
to take my final freshman exams.
I remember being on the highway and thinking
how I kind of expected my parents to freak out a little.
And to my surprise, they had not freaked out.
They'd been calm and cool and collected,
oddly calm, cool, and collected.
But still, I was really happy as I drove back to school.
Meanwhile, subsequent events were
busy unfolding back home.
My mother was going through the house where I grew up
and was gathering together things I had made for her.
A jewelry box when I was in 4-H, and a painting when I was 16.
A box containing the letters that I'd
written them from school, which I used to do every week.
She was removing photographs from the walls
and placing them in little piles around the house.
And she was directing my father, who never dared not follow
her direction, to take the bed and the desk and the chair
and the lamp and the Smith Corona, Smith Corona even,
and to put them all in the front yard next to the rock garden,
not too close to the maple tree.
My clothes, my books, my bookcases, my report cards,
my Farrah Fawcett posters, my shoes,
three years worth of interview magazines,
the good ones with the Andy Warhol covers, everything.
Then with my brother and my sister and my grandparents
watching, my mother removed a cigarette
from this tiny crocheted case she always kept them in.
And she lit the cigarette, and then she took the match
and put it to the pile of things there in the front yard that
contained the sole and complete record of my existence
and my family.
It burned for 7 and 1 half hours,
thanks in part to the addition of some lighter fluid
to help get the larger pieces of furniture going.
All of it, all that was me prior to that memorable Memorial
Day up in flames.
According to my sister, who years later recounted
these details to me, it was a mighty impressive blaze.
In their eagerness to feed it, and due to an unexpected wind
off the fields around the house, the sugar maple
that was older than my great grandfather
caught a spark in its branches and was sacrificed.
They cut off all communication with me.
They emptied and closed our joint bank account.
There goes college.
They barred the door.
They stopped talking, stopped answering my letters,
stopped taking my calls.
They stopped anything with me.
They just stopped.
I was completely disbelieving.
I mean, this didn't make any sense.
All of my friends had stories about telling
their families they were gay, and they all ended the same way.
Sooner or later, everything worked out fine.
So I even had a friend named Neil,
whose parents had done the same thing.
At first, they just stopped talking to him.
But one year later, they were inviting his new boyfriend
to come home with him for the holidays.
Everyone counseled me to have a little patience
and have a little hope.
And this is how it starts, slowly, just a little hope,
just enough to get you through.
But hope is cumulative.
A little bit here and a little bit there,
it builds up in the system until it becomes something toxic.
Denial.
I mean, their reaction had been, yes, extreme,
but not the worst that could happen.
The thing to do was to be a good son, to make them proud,
to earn back their love.
So I got a job, and then another, and then a third.
Three shifts, three restaurants, six days a week.
That would show them.
But they weren't watching.
I wrote them letters, lots of letters, about nothing.
It's Tuesday, and it's hot.
Or my new roommate is named Kathy.
Or my friends took me out for my birthday yesterday.
They didn't write back.
Living, for me, sort of came to a halt,
despite the fact that my life just went on and on.
I didn't think about my future.
I didn't think about my needs.
I didn't think about my sadness.
I didn't think about any of it.
I didn't have to, because I had hope.
Every day, whispering in my ear, don't give up.
Don't walk away.
You're almost there.
Don't stop.
Don't grow.
Don't develop.
Don't worry.
Just don't make any sudden movements, or you'll blow it.
So six years went on like this, without a word from them.
So finally, hurt and confused beyond my ability
to hold it in, and frankly, finding it really
difficult to maintain the illusion
that this was temporary.
I decided to make one more attempt to force the issue.
So I flew home and showed up unannounced at my mother's
office.
It was an amazing visit.
I asked the receptionist to page my mother
and tell her she had a surprise visitor.
And I stood there in the lobby, and I
remember seeing my mother come down this long hallway
toward me.
And she was walking, and then she sort of looked up,
and she saw me.
And then she recognized who it was,
and she turned and walked away again.
It was a really amazing 90-second visit.
Two and a half weeks later, a black funeral wreath
was delivered to me at my office with a note that
said, in memory of our son.
Clearly, it was time to give up hope and take up therapy.
So I talked to a counselor who asked me
why I had invited this turmoil into my life.
I talked to a minister who suggested a Christian youth
camp.
I talked to a lesbian who offered
to slash my mother's tires if I paid for her flight there.
I signed up for scream therapy, where
I beat pillows with tennis rackets
and screamed obscenities and pulled
a muscle in my shoulder.
Mostly I talked to friends, and mostly the pain persisted.
The sheer weight of it nearly crushed me,
or at least that's how it felt at the time.
Since it was my constant companion,
I spent most of my time turning it over in my mind,
fingering it like some sort of psychological worry stone.
Over the years, it's been eroded by so much handling.
All that remains now is a small, hard, nearly weightless pebble,
really.
Worn away is most of the anger and much of the hurt.
But one question remains.
How was it possible that they taught me
love and loyalty in excess of that which they themselves
possessed?
I have come to believe that it's not
possible to understand what they did.
Not possible for me, anyway.
To understand it would seem to indicate
that there was some justification for it,
and I know for certain that there is not.
Still, there's no escaping my parents.
This thing they did, this extreme and unfathomable
and many layered thing they did, tore a hole
in the middle of my life.
I have spent years and a lot of money
darning that hole while trying to keep the rest of my world
from unraveling.
And yet, their influence on me is enduring.
My parents loved me terribly.
I have been courageous in the face of bullies.
There is such a thing as too much patience,
but no such thing as too much forgiveness.
And love has seen me through every misfortune.
Thank you.